here on gigas well calm /g 3 delighted
to be joined by Abby thresher great
surname thank you I'm so you love it you
play much quake 3 back in the day no
sadly I didn't well you're here showing
us at the latest and central game and
you guys unveiled this just a couple of
weeks ago explain for the folks at home
what makes this one different and also
in the wake of this hole connect
craziness sure so this is Dance Central
spotlight it's a completely digital
title it's sort of like a spiritual
successor to our last dance central game
this game focuses on customization it
ships with a core soundtrack of 10 songs
and then a music store full of options
for the player to customize their game
experience another big difference is
this time around each song in the game
comes not with three or four routines
but with eight so you can work your way
up from beginner to pro if that's the
way you like to play or you can focus on
fitness or try lots of other different
stylistic routines so that initial as 10
games is up is that a free download as
it were and then the library is what's
open for you if you want more songs so
we haven't talked pricing yet love more
information about that later but the
game will be affordable and yeah the
song library the in-game music store
will be chock full of stuff another cool
thing is that if you previously owned
any of our titles and you had bought DLC
for them your DLC will be available to
you free of charge in this game and each
of those songs will also have four
brand-new routines included yeah sounds
like a lot of work it's a big backlog of
DLC what about say DLC is carrying over
what about songs tracks dances that
people had on their previous versions
non-central like just these be boxed
versions so we haven't we don't have the
capability to do the disc songs at this
time
so we're just focusing on the DLP back
catalogue there you guys gonna sell them
as individuals song as you think are you
gonna do it as packs I know for a lot of
the rhythm games for instance that was
all the time that was the way to do it
set them in groups of three or four yeah
I think we're still working on that up
but the big thing is we've increased our
production pipeline significantly so
that we'll be able to start delivering
content while songs are still charting
so we can deliver routines and dances
much faster than ever before and just
kind of give people new stuff to dance
to all the time I guess that was
probably a big problem before when
you're relying on retail distribution is
that you maybe you were two weeks away
from the latest craze yeah it was it was
harder in the past you know it was a
process that was pretty labor intensive
and time intensive and now we'll have
more information this summer but it's
kind of lightning fast it's pretty cool
what was the mentality behind releasing
it like this Ali is it did you guys see
a lot of people the people who are sort
of really invested in down Central find
quite a lot of stuff at digitally yes so
we sort of have just been paying
attention to away the markets been going
and digital downloads are a huge thing
especially with the Xbox one we're
seeing more and more consumers looking
to just download their titles fully we
also paid a lot of attention to the way
that people were playing Dance Central
and there was a lot of requests for
customization for options for people who
kind of liked to play around the easier
standard difficulties and then for the
hard core there were people who are like
okay I can do this now what what's next
so this game is all about serving it
basically every facet of the dance
central market
obviously Microsoft a couple of weeks
ago announced that they were going to
take Kinect out of the box I was talking
to John Drake abettor there on one of
our shows a couple of weeks ago took you
guys a little bit by surprise that guys
how do you think does that change the
way in which you sort of tackle what
dances you put into this game because
you're a bit extra but you're going to
have a a smaller market than you would
have let's say I don't think it
necessarily changes the way I mean we're
still connect developers so we're still
looking to kind of focus on bringing
genre-defining experiences a really
robust gameplay for the Kinect camera
and take advantage of everything that
the new camera has to offer us Don
Central spotlight how many F players can
you have on screen any one time so you
can have up to two people at a time it's
you know like I said it's kind of a
spiritual successor it's a little bit
stripped-down but it's pretty awesome
you can drop in and drop out with each
other you can also play Fitness mode
together you can see Jessa is choosing
her routines here so there's lots of
options but yes it's a hell of a good
time are those our difficulty modes and
then the sort of fitness regime stuff
too yep yeah so fitness mode will have
more info later this summer but
basically you kind of pick the routines
that you like to play like if you're a
crazy person and you like to just play
the most difficult routines but those
input in the amount of time and the game
kind of generates a playlist for you so
that you can just dance your little
heart out excellent and you'll be softs
a press conference yesterday or the day
before yesterday and they released their
latest version of Just Dance which I
guess is your kind of main rival in this
little space and they've decided to sort
of pull away from the reliance on
connectors of where they've got the the
app with the phone and do you think that
that is a an effective way to capture
dance or do you think like connect sort
of the is a much more realistic way or a
much more engaging way of dancing in
front of your television so we focus on
Kinect because we take of our approach
is always kind of on an accuracy and
connect provides us a lot of opportunity
to track your full body but hey anything
that gets people dancing and moving and
dancing outside of their living rooms is
awesome very political answer I like a
very good Ally
alright I'm gonna put this bad boy down
do you guys have you see have you talked
at all about pricing a relation to
individual dancers what were they before
when you were when you were when you
were had your store was a 99 cents or
something or that's the question for
someone who wears a blazer in this
business okay if Nick testers in the
back we'll we'll pull them over here how
do you know how many songs you're gonna
launch with as well Nick sailing at me
$2 $2 $2 dollar 99 all right Donald I'm
not even two dollars I'm in sweatpants I
make the game I don't know do you have
any idea how many did you say 10 songs
10 dancers you're gonna start with yep
10 10 songs with 8 routines each so 80
dances to start with okay I do you've
any ID told anyone what what what what
are we listening to now because there's
a quite a lot of ambient noise happening
here like right now if you can hear it
we've got happy by Pharrell Williams and
then the other songs we've announced so
far are show me kid ink and Chris Brown
sock dirty to me Jason Derulo wake me up
by Avicii and Counting stars by
OneRepublic thank you nice a nice breath
does it work
oh here we go and there's some there's
some Pro feel like this is the theme
song of e3 2014 and it's been quite a
lot of different press trailers and
whatnot so you guys have been shopping
the Saran do you think people kind of
get the concept of this because it is a
bit of a departure from what you were
doing like in many ways it's very
similar but in terms of its packaging
it's very different do you think people
have sort of grabbed onto the concept
yeah so far the cool thing I mean this
is way more accessible than our previous
titles so we're kind of hoping to hook a
lot of brand-new dancers and it's kind
of been cool showing at e3 I mean we've
had people from all walks of life's just
sort of giggling laughing hysterically
jumping in trying out beginner trying
out standard trying out the fitness
stuff it's awesome
and the breadth of people who play the
Don Central games it's one of those
games are sort of it's not you know
maybe it's not for core gamers but it is
for lots of core core games that were
getting into productive categories but
it does reach out into different age
groups young and old do you think that
them those age groups are sort of in
tune with digital purchasing that this
is something that they'll be able to
talk uh pretty easily oh definitely yeah
yeah totally what song are we going into
now do you know oh I don't know I wasn't
watching what's what's what song we
doing wake me up by Avicii how long have
you been dancing today dancing yesterday
oh yeah and the day before is it does e3
like this if you feel the burn yeah can
you can you talk to a microphone and
dance at the same time no I think you
can I think if we try if you talk us
through the dance through the dance are
you gonna dance with me I don't think I
my hands can't do that I don't think
with the microphone
I love how everyone's got its own I've
always liked how you've named every
single move that is part of my job is
naming all the moves okay
what's the best move Nick could clap
tops pretty easy let's be honest a bunch
of the choreographers named a bunch of
things after me and one of them is a
move where you just sort of bash your
hands and shake your head I'm one let's
just named after you it's not the alley
it's called the Thrasher even better
even better
I made for it jessa right now is
actually dancing one of the alternate
pro routines so these are kind of for
our our like Dance Central hardcore
Fults so these are stylistically
different and they're also big
difficulty jump from from the standard
difficulty row that the game ships with
so you can see she's gonna get pretty
like lyrical and then she'll go into
some housing moves and kind of just go
crazy man I always wish I could whenever
I see the stage folks the pros doing
this it's like because like I'm gonna be
completely honest the times I've enjoyed
down section the most have been two in
the morning when I've come in from a
pretty late night and it feels like I'm
doing really good that's when your
talent is unlocked my inhibitions just
sort of fall to the floor and the real
dancer inside of me it just breaks free
and lets you really be the real you we
talked a little bit about the Just Dance
Dance Central I'm gonna call it a
rivalry and do you think is that space
the dancing sort of space because you
know we could talk about Guitar Hero and
obviously rock band like there was a
peak in a valley in that like it sort of
week we reached peak music game there a
while ago and then perhaps we will have
another shot of it again soon but um do
you feel like there's still a lot of
interest in this is it growing or do you
feel like you're appealing to the same
people matter you have won for a while
so the cool thing is the market is
definitely growing and you know being on
that Xbox one is definitely a new
opportunity for us to reach lots of
folks I think dancing kind of taps into
something really really primal for
people like the ability to move to move
to music to move on beats I mean you
look at little kids babies intuitively
like pop along when you play them music
so it definitely kind of strikes a chord
with people at a different level so you
know I think dancing games are kind of
here to say any kind of games that get
you moving physic
pretty awesome have you had any videos
of toddlers using the Kinect can our
gonna reach them gonna pick up on the
little they're gonna it's it's
surprising it's we've had kids in the
office like people's kids kind of wander
in and just like it picks them up and
little kids are always way better at
this I asked my friend's daughter who is
in the office the other day to teach me
how to play this game and she just
totally gave me like six year old side
eye and was like ally seriously it's so
you just push the button you push the
button and then you dance and she was
just like how do you not how do you not
get this you're an adult what's wrong
with you
their whole generation of kids in their
just growing up dancing in front of
televisions who think it's completely
normal
oh it's only and playing with tablet
wait yeah like the kids you see them
like they get a newspaper and they're
like trying to zoom us and it's not
working like what is the thing physical
media I don't understand
I guess that's an interesting thing
about these games is that like maybe
maybe I'm not to call myself a prude are
all like I'm 28 years old I so I've been
around awhile while I connect has been
around but it is interesting that like
there is this whole other market that
will always be going because it's young
people growing up that is just used to
stand in front of televisions and
playing instruments and dancing and
stuff and not not giving a care in the
world not having any inhibitions I guys
I know they live in the future I'm like
you and I they live in the future you're
live in the future come on you're
shopping and stuff ran all the time I
don't know how much how much longer
we've got and before we keep on going
you could just say it to my ear because
I'm on the run town
you can feel free to check out the
bayonet oh yeah okay all right I think
we're done here Ali thank you so much
for coming on and showing us non-central
spotlight thank you so much for dancing
let's get doing someone's like dee sweat
her a night what did somebody like that
dives you downer all right stick around
here at Gamescom for Sashi three and we
got super smash bros off next up on
samsung stage but now I look at
Bayonetta 2